I accidentally... It's fine.
It's fine.
I started my stream.
I started my next stream.
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, I'm not live.
Sorry guys, I accidentally raided this stream.
I accidentally raided this stream.
Oh my god.
Alright, we're doing the... Should we chat our stuff first or should we raid now?
Should we do the pillaging?
We probably don't need to do the pillaging.
Hold on, I have so many DMs real quick.
Okay, guys, I accidentally raided Min's stream instead of my mom's stream.
I have so many DMs.
Hold on.
Okay, okay.
Someone said the pillager is not worth the risk.
Okay, let's just enchant stuff then.
You work on enchanting.
I'm just gonna work on...
Um, do you want the... I'll put the enderpearls in your chest and then I'll put the books in yours.
Do you want me to make bookshelves now?
I can make it now.
Um, hold on.
Oh god, wait.
How many bookshelves do we need?
Um, I don't know.
Guys, how many do we need for the enchanting table?
Oh yeah, yeah.
How many do we need?
You have more.
Can you get past the bookshelf books to me and I'll make them?
Yeah, I have that many.
Oh my god!
Okay, we have enough.
We have enough for bookshelves.
Yeah, we have so many.
Fifteen?
Okay, we have...
But we still need books for the enchanting stuff, so... Oh, I see.
Oh, so we have nine right now.
Um, I'm gonna go farm some more trees real quick.
Wait, is it night time?
Night time!
Sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep!
I'm asleep in my bed.
I'm asleep too.
I'm asleep as well.
Guys, we have one life.
If we don't do this, it's over.
We'll try this again another time.
Try what?
What are we trying?
If we fuck it up...
We have one life to make this happen.
One life to make what happen?
The Ender Dragon.
We have one life.
We have one life to make this work.
Oh, chat is frozen.
Thank you guys.
Sorry.
Thank you for letting... Yeah, yeah.
I forgot to change my chat overlay as well.
Thank you.
Me too.
Alright.
Guys, we just came right back into it.
We just came right back.
One life to make it all work.
Ender Dragon.
Alright.
Okay, I got the wood.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
I got enough for... I think I got enough for bookshelves.
Yeah, I do.
I do.
We got this.
Uh...
Wood.
And then I should have... I should have enough for 15.
Let's see.
Bookshelf.
That's where if we...
You know what I think might happen?
What?
I won't be surprised if...
Just there.
What?
What do you mean by that?
Just there.
You think we're gonna die?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We're not.
Well, we can do this.
Oh, we need glass, so I need to get...
Sand.
Sand is right next to us.
Oh, what's the glass for?
The potion bottles?
Yeah.
Wait, is that... What else do you need to make potion bottles?
Oh, I haven't unlocked it, so I don't know yet.
I think that's it.
Oh, you just need to get glass and then...
Oh, we had so many empty bottles too and we threw it all away.
It's fine.
I didn't need it.
Okay.
It's fine.
They don't stack, so it sucks.
That's true, that's true.
13...
14.
I have 15.
And we have 38 books too.
So, yeah, I'll put the bookshelves with you.
Okay.
I can help you with glass too.
What else do I need for the bottles?
Wait, give me...
Oh, I need to make the glass.
Give me the shovel.
I'll get glass and then you can work on enchanting table and stuff.
Do you have any coal?
I do.
It's in my other box.
It's in my other chest.
Give me the glass and I'll dig the sand and then you work on enchanting table.
Okay.
Alright.
I mean, sand is literally right here.
Yeah, just get some.
Yeah, just grab some.
Yeah.
Oh, I need to make...
We're being... We're being... We're so productive right now.
We're teamwork.
Teamwork.
Teamwork right here.
Teamwork makes the dream work.
Right here.
Okay.
I got...
46.
I think 46 is enough.
Probably, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll burn... I'll start burning the glass.
Yeah.
Alright.
Burn it up, baby.
Burn it up.
Does the blast furnace work with sand?
Oh, it does.
I don't think so.
Wait, does it not?
No, it does not.
Okay, it's fine.
We have...
Someone said, what if the end portal is 12 blocks... 12k blocks away?
Don't say that.
There's no way.
We don't have Elijah.
Stop saying that, please.
If it's too far, we're calling it.
If it's too far...
We're going in here.
So we just need the 15 bookshelves around, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just surround it.
Okay, I'm making this stuff.
Alright.
It's like that, right guys?
I think so, yeah.
Like that, like that.
Then you put the...
Thing in the middle, yeah.
Is it?
Did it work?
Yeah, now we need the lapis.
Okay, I have the lapis block.
On the corners?
Oh.
It's fine.
I have...
Here.
Here, let me see it.
62.
How many levels do you have?
30.
35.
You can get knockback.
Yeah, it goes all the way to 3.
Enchantment, knockback, smite.
Here's...
Do we want...
I can enchant the bow.
Actually.
Power!
I should get that, right?
For the bow?
That's for the bow, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll put that for the bow then.
Right?
What?
Is that right, guys?
Is that...
Do I do it?
Oh, yeah.
Infinity on the bow would be so good.
Okay.
I have power.
I have power for...
So it goes to unbreaking 3.
So we're good, guys.
We're good.
I have power 4 on my bow.
Nice.
Should I do unbreaking on my sword or...
Alright, and then I can...
I can't remember what the enchantments are.
I can just...
And then I'm just gonna...
If we have bad luck, where's the rest of the books?
Here, I put the rest of the books here.
Okay, we can just put some...
On your right side.
Yeah, I got them.
We can just reset with this.
I need anvil.
You have all my iron, right?
Oh, yeah.
Here you go.
Pass it over.
Oh, blast protection.
That would be...
That's good.
Yeah.
Hold on.
Here you go.
There you go.
I'm gonna see if I have...
Oh, 32.
That's enough for an anvil.
Oh, armor enchant.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Armor enchant.
Anvil.
Wait, how do I make an anvil?
Wait, do I need more?
Blast protection 4 is good, right?
No, it's not.
Wait, feather falling.
We need feather falling.
Yeah.
Oh, let me check my boots.
How do I make anvil again?
Iron blocks?
How many do I need?
Yeah, you need some iron blocks.
Okay, 3.
Okay, I have enough.
3.
Oh.
Oh, I do.
I just had enough.
That's good.
Alright.
I just had enough for an anvil.
Flat protection is best.
Okay.
And then we have protection 1.
Okay, let's...
What else can we get?
Let's try our helmet instead.
Sick.
I'm breaking...
I'm breaking projectile protection.
Fix my bow.
Gotta fix my bow.
Yeah, let's check the bow.
Let's try the bow.
Power 4...
Power 4 would be good on the bow, right?
Yeah, it would be good.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, I also got extra unbreaking on it.
Oh, nice!
Okay, I need to take my shoes off.
Okay.
Okay, cool.
Death Strider.
Okay, oh, projectile protection.
Just explain how I'm too tired to think.
Projectile...
I don't know, do we need...
I don't think projectile protection...
No, just say...
They all said normal protection is better than projectile.
Yeah, but my thing doesn't make that.
Well, just do something else and then you can unlock...
Unbreaking 3...
Oh, I got protection 3 on my boots.
Oh, I don't have...
Protection 3...
Protect 3.
Okay, thanks guys.
Where's my pants?
Unbreaking 3, protection 2.
Oh, I have protection 2!
Maybe I'll get the feather fall.
I'm gonna get protection 2.
Oh...
Wait...
Oh, I can't do more on my boots.
No, we don't have enough XP!
We should be fine, right?
What XP do you need?
I have level 27.
Oh, I need...
Yeah, sharpness and sweeping edge.
Let me just...
Let me see what I have.
How do I combine?
What do I do?
Use books.
You put...
Oh my god.
I didn't realize my glasses were on.
Glasses.
No, I have protection 3 for my chest.
I need that.
I'm breaking up sharpness.
Oh, I'm just gonna get sharpness.
Fuck it.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna kill something.
Okay...
It might be me.
I have on my head...
I have protection respiration.
Why are they all such shitty levels?
Okay.
I'm just gonna commit with these.
I think...
I think this is fine.
How should I get some more levels, guys?
How do you get more levels really fast?
I have more on my feet.
I'm breaking 3 power protection.
Oh my god, I'm breaking 3.
Oh my god, I'm asleep.
Okay.
I'm just checking my chest plate real fast.
I'm breaking 3.
You guys are so funny.
To the leather.
No, don't do that to us.
Mine's in coal.
Where can I find some coal?
Don't do that.
Min and I are two different types of sleepiness.
You're just... you're fatigued.
I'm just delusional.
Oh my god, there's dogs!
I can't get to the home.
Oh my gosh, but the dogs went to home.
Get the dogs.
I can kill a bunch of animals.
Kill.
I'm in my kill era.
I also, we have the leather books.
Leather and paper for books.
Oh yeah.
I think we have like 30.
We have a lot of books now.
But just in case we're trying to get feather falling.
Oh, that's true.
To refresh the enchantments, right?
Yeah, or something, you know.
Um...
I don't want to get my bones.
It's 430 and you're dying?
I'm already dead.
I can't die anymore.
That's why it's just an actual hell for me.
You're just in hell.
I'm just in hell.
Because I'm tired.
I want to die, but I can't die.
What do you do when you can't die again?
What do you...
I wish we didn't die those three times.
Wait, there's two dogs here.
Yeah, I'm trying to get them right now.
I'm trying to get those two dogs.
I'm trying to get them in my fucking army.
They will be the clutch.
This dog took four of my...
Oh my god.
Okay, this one's not picky.
Oh, there's coal here.
But there's a zombie too.
They're not picky.
You're gonna die here.
I'm so happy.
You know what?
I'm ready.
I'm ready to go.
Ready to go where?
I'm ready to...
I'm ready to find the stronghold.
I'm so ready, man.
I'm fucking... I'm ready to...
I'm ready to go in.
Yes, we will.
I'm so ready.
You don't know that.
I feel like...
I feel so strong.
I feel so strong now.
I feel like...
I don't know.
I just feel something in me.
I'm locked in.
We're gonna kill those...
I'm gonna kill those fucking...
I'm locking in.
I'm locking in with my aimbot.
I'm gonna lock in.
I'm gonna hit those towers.
And then it's gonna be so easy.
I've done it before.
I can do it again.
I can...
I'm not delusional.
I swear to god.
I'm not...
I'm not delusional.
I can hit those...
I can hit those blocks.
It's gonna be so easy to hit them.
I swear.
It's gonna be so easy.
I'm not the Lulu.
I know I'm not.
I am.
Oh my gosh.
I mined so much.
And I didn't even get anything.
Wait, what dogs are you trying to get?
I already got them.
I got the two dogs.
There's two more dogs over here.
How many fucking dogs are there?
I don't have another bone though.
I already got my bones.
Are we mining the quartz?
No, we're not.
I'm going in.
We have to get a lot of levels, don't we?
Don't go in, Mint.
Don't go in.
This is the one I'm going in.
How did you get...
How did you get the obsidian?
We have one more.
Don't come with me, dogs.
Where I'm going, I don't know if I'm coming back.
Where I'm going...
Where I'm going, I don't know.
I need to go back.
I forgot to bring my gold armor.
Get me back in.
Why isn't it getting me back in?
I almost didn't make it back.
There's a gold nugget.
Where's my gold chest?
That's the gold armor I threw away.
I can make a helmet.
I can make a helmet real quick.
There we go.
Alright, here I go.
Get me all your phantom membranes.
I got my one phantom membrane.
Where I'm going, I don't know if I'm coming back, Mint.
If you don't come back, then we're dead.
What do you mean your one phantom membrane?
There's nothing in here.
It's in your other chest.
I put it in your other chest.
No, it's not.
There's only two chests here.
I took it back.
I accidentally took it back.
It's back in my inventory.
I'm coming back.
I'm here.
Here, put it back.
I put it back.
Okay, thanks.
I got it.
I put it back.
I'm going back again.
I'm going back.
Where's the redstone?
It's in your other chest.
Yeah, I got it.
Okay, guys.
To make this, I...
Oh wait, where's the glass?
The glass is in here.
I can make a bottle.
I'm ending the course.
I'm at level 26.
They do stack.
They don't stack when there's stuff in it.
Oh, yeah.
That's basically it.
Okay, so I put the...
the excited...
the powder in here.
How much levels should I get?
Where is it in here?
Wait, then the exciting stuff in here.
Oh, we need the water.
Yeah, we need the water.
How many what?
How many levels?
I'm at level 26 now.
Get as many as you can.
Okay, I'll get as many.
Just let me know when to come back.
When you're done with everything else, then I'll come back.
I'm just gonna keep farming until you're done with everything else.
Okay.
And then you have to know every other prep stuff and then we just...
we just go.
But I also need to get levels.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
When you're done...
When I get to 30, we swap.
I'm gonna leave some...
I'm gonna leave some quartz for you.
I'm leaving some easy quartz.
I'm gonna go for the harder ones.
How do I make the eye of the ender?
We need...
The blaze rods thing first?
We have the blaze rods.
Oh my god, I have blaze rods.
I'm coming back down.
I'm coming back.
You just took everything.
I did.
I did take everything.
I just never... I never had...
I never had it in my inventory.
Oh, cook the quartz for XP?
That's what they're for?
Yeah, the quartz are for XP.
Oh, I thought they meant farming them.
I thought they just meant farming them.
I didn't realize cooking them.
Where's this BGM?
This is my mental state right now.
My BGM.
That's how I feel right now.
I don't know how the others...
Are you listening to the fart competition too?
What?
What are you talking about?
What are you...
The song!
You said your BGM!
I could put it on if you guys would listen to it.
Wait, you can cook the quartz?
Oh my god, I got one guy.
I got one guy.
They were like...
Okay, I gave you my blaze rods.
The blaze rods are in.
And I put emerald.
I think that's...
And I put all the lapis stuff.
I'm going back in.
Oh, we have to pick it up with silk touch.
We don't have that.
Oh wait, it's here.
I have a song, you guys.
Here you go.
This is the fart competition.
Music.
Alright.
When I hit 30, I'll let you...
I'll let you farm the other quartz.
I think we need...
30 is the minimum.
So we can have one more...
30 would be like one more enchantment that we get to have.
On level 30.
Cool.
There's so many quartz.
Thank god there's so many quartz.
Yes.
Okay.
Up we go.
Oh my god, it's over here.
It's over here.
Huh?
You're alive, okay?
You're alive.
Sorry.
Oh shit, we gotta sleep.
Oh shit.
Oh, I'm coming back.
Wait, can you sleep if I'm in the nether?
No, you have to be sleeping too.
Okay, I'm coming back.
I'm coming back.
I'm heading back right now.
I'm running.
I'm fucking running over.
I'm running back.
I'm fucking running.
You wanna swap over so you can farm the quartz?
I left a lot of quartz to the right.
Okay, I got it.
I'm sleeping.
I'm here.
I just don't wanna kill the pigs.
I feel like I'm gonna fucking die if I do.
I dropped some gold for you.
Oh, okay.
Guys, I feel like if I try to kill the pigmen, I will die.
Guys, I will 100% die if I try to kill them.
There's no way.
There's no way I will live.
What happened?
Why am I coming back
to my house?
It's not gonna hurt you.
He literally came out swinging his sword.
What?
Why?
And now he's a zombie.
I don't know why.
How did he...
How did we have an invader?
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna do something really crazy.
He's a zombie now.
I'm gonna do something...
I'm gonna do something very crazy.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna try and kill these pigs.
For XP.
What pigs?
Oh, the regular pigmen?
Yeah, I'm gonna do it.
Oh, I can kill this guy.
Yeah, kill him.
Take his stuff.
Oh my god, here's some gold stuff too.
Alright.
Okay, I'm gonna do something very crazy.
I'm gonna put a spectral arrow.
And then...
Okay, so I first do the nether wart, right?
Okay.
Do the wart.
And then I do...
Okay, I'm...
Yes.
This might be how I die.
Do I put it in here or in here?
This could be it.
Wart, membrane.
This could be how I die.
Wait, there's a lot of pigmen.
Maybe I'm not gonna do this.
Actually, I'm just gonna farm cores.
Wart, membrane, redstone.
Put it...
Of course I saw it here.
Oh, I have to fuel it with the blaze powder.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Yeah, you guys, I realized how bad of an idea that was.
I'm already in too deep.
Alright.
You're doing it.
I'm level 30.
You can go and farm some cores if you need to.
I'm gonna make a trail for you to follow.
Follow this trail.
To farm cores for levels.
I made a torch trail.
Follow it and then you'll find lots of cores around you.
Now the membrane.
I got it.
I made a torch trail for you.
Is it working?
Where do I need the blaze powder to?
I'm here.
Oh, next to the redstone.
I'm gonna check for...
Did it work?
Don't mind the gold.
Just remember not to mind the gold.
But it's not long.
It's not long.
Wait, but it's only a minute and thirty.
Oh, redstone now.
Okay, okay.
Breaking projectiles.
Okay, now redstone.
There we go.
We're doing it.
I need to reset.
How do I reset again?
Do I just put a book in here?
Is that it?
Yeah, you have to reset your gacha with something else.
Like with my book, right?
Yeah, I think so.
And it resets all three?
Yeah.
You have all the other books.
Oh, I have books.
Yeah, you can pass me.
And the lapis, here you go.
Okay, uh...
What do I not need?
Alright, let's reset.
Awkward potions, awkward potions.
Um...
Wait, I need the blaze powder here.
I guess I'll...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I'm scared.
I'll do this then.
I'll reset level one.
It's still powered.
Oh, okay.
Now I go back to...
Wait, what do I get then?
Projectile...
Oh, I see!
Fire protection, blast protection 2.
Oh, blast protection 2!
We're doing it.
The blaze rod should last us a while.
Blast protection!
Oh, blast protection 4!
Oh, nice!
Yeah, there's a blast protection 4 here.
Okay.
Alright.
Back in there we go.
Almost forgot.
I almost forgot something.
Oh, wait, you don't want the blast protection.
You want regular protection.
Oh.
Oh!
I keep forgetting.
Okay.
Okay, so I have to reset again.
And then we do a redstone.
You know, I don't want to just hold on to it.
Okay.
How many levels do we need for...
What level are you now?
25.
But I'm about to be at 0.
But how are you about to be 0?
Because I want to put the protection on my chest.
No, it just takes a couple of levels.
It doesn't take the whole thing.
Oh.
Never mind.
It just takes a couple.
Okay, where are the other quartz?
Oh my god.
At the membrane.
Where are the other quartz?
Oh, not the soul sand.
Why is the soul sand right next to us?
I need like one more.
Okay.
Okay, I'll leave this for you.
I'll leave this.
I'll leave this for you.
And then I'm gonna...
Yeah, because don't you need them for farm?
I left you...
Quartz.
I left you quartz.
Levels.
Don't you need the levels?
Yeah.
One life.
One life, guys.
If we don't make it here, it's over.
We'll do this next time.
When we're not...
When we're more prepared.
I watched the video.
Who would've thought it would take us...
Four hours.
It wasn't us.
It's not even our fault.
It was the fortress.
It wasn't even our fault.
It was the fucking fortress.
We could've fucking finished this so long ago.
With the fucking fortress.
Protection 2.
Blast protection.
What am I putting here?
Where am I at?
Wait, the membrane.
Just protection.
Okay.
Do I reset?
I'll just get this.
I'll just get the radio protection.
Oh, shit.
I feel like if I just...
Yeah, I don't wanna...
Okay, and then...
Okay, and then that should reset the others too, right?
Protection 4!
Let's go!
Okay, helmet's protection 4.
And then...
Feet is also protection 4.
Okay, I'll get the helmet.
Okay, we got all the slow fallings.
Hopefully that's enough.
Alright, you can go grind some quartz first.
Because I've been hogging the quartz.
Hold on, I gotta make more potions.
Okay.
Alright, I'll go check if I can find other ways to grind.
I'll just go for the harder quartz to find.
Okay, then...
I can do...
I'll just go for the harder places to find quartz.
So I don't take the easy ones.
I made torches.
Pathway for you to get the easy ones.
For quartz.
So...
This should be fine.
We're not gonna...
Guys, we're not...
We're not...
We can't cook quartz.
We got lied to before and it doesn't work.
Cooking quartz doesn't work.
It's all fake news.
What am I cooking quartz?
It said you can cook quartz, but you have to use silk touch the quartz to cook them.
What?
I've never heard that.
Copper on furnace can give you good XP.
Oh, put copper in furnace.
We have a lot of copper.
I don't need fire resist, but it breathes fire.
Oh, regen potion.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, you had a gas tier.
Okay, I got it.
I thought you had some too.
I do.
I have three.
I remember you had some as well.
Okay.
So now I do the gas tier and then I do the brick stone as usual.
I forgot I can...
Wait, so what was the point of the magma?
I think there was no point.
I think they were trying to tell us it was useless.
Breathe weird purple pain gas.
That's weird.
Oh, it's for the fortress.
Wait, we don't have...
Wait, what?
The glowstone?
Wouldn't it be better if it lasted longer than the glowstone?
Okay, I'm mining.
I'm mining.
Alright, I got...
I got some...
I'll put some coins.
If I get two more, I can get protection four on both of my fucking items.
Do you know...
Do you see any glowstone in there?
Yeah, I can get some.
What do you need glowstone for?
For the potions.
Okay, I'll grab them then.
I wish making potions gave you experience.
You can put some stuff in the furnace.
I have nothing though.
Don't we have like copper?
I thought we had copper.
I thought we had a lot of copper.
I don't see it.
I think you got rid of all the copper.
Oh, I might have.
Am I throwing them away?
Honestly, I'm not surprised.
Okay, I got that experience.
Oh, there's a meat.
Thanks, guys.
Oh, I have lots of meat.
Right here.
I'm gonna have to grab some more rocks here.
So I can make sure not to accidentally mine the gold.
I'll go grab the glowstone.
What is happening?
We're doing the final preparation.
Can I cook the ancient debris in the blast furnace?
You can, I'm pretty sure, right?
It seems like you could.
Okay.
I've lost my grip of reality when I thought I had two dogs.
What am I cooking?
I'm scared.
Will it still work?
Oh wait, it turned into scrap.
I remember it turning into scrap.
It'll go away.
It's gonna go away.
It's gonna...
It's gonna go away, guys.
The gas is gonna go away.
Don't...
The gas will go away.
The gas is gonna go away, I believe.
I believe.
The blast furnace gives you half XP?
No way.
I knew it was gonna go away.
That's a scam.
I can't believe it.
How did they do 20 days of this?
They were barely alive.
They were...
Did you watch all of it?
No, I watched some of it, but they were not alive.
I think like by day 7, they weren't even like alive anymore.
They weren't even there anymore.
It was just...
It's so sad.
I remember that day.
Paisenat and Speed, when they did their infamous Minecraft challenge, they were not alive.
They like... Okay, you know what's really... They like streamed their showers and everything too.
Yeah!
They were in their swimming trunks, but they were like you know, they basically showered on stream and everything.
I have glowstone.
I put it in your potion box thing.
Trying to find more animals to kill.
I'm hungry for blood.
Alright, I'm gonna enchant my boots.
Boots, boots, boots, boots.
Oh, armadillo, I could never hurt you.
What the hell is this?
What the fuck?
I don't have feather falling on it though, so that's unfortunate, but that's the best I can do.
What is this thing?
I got an armadillo scoot.
Oh, that's to make the armor.
That's to make the armor.
You can make armor for your dog.
Yeah, you're the one that told me that.
I know, but I didn't know what it was when I grabbed it.
Oh, I put glow dust in the area.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Also, we're gonna have to really stock up on food, so we'll have to...
I have a lot of bread, so...
But meat gives more...
Okay, I have
cows or...
Any of them.
I'm grabbing some of them.
I can kill some of them right now.
I'm heading over.
I'm fucking ready for blood.
I can go to the courts.
Yeah, you go farm courts.
I'll go get some meat for us.
Okay.
I was just trying to make these.
I put glow dust too.
You wanna put stuff in the glow dust?
And...
Wait, does water work in the ender?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Oh my god.
You can have a scoot.
You can see how ugly it looks.
Oh no, I'm pretty sure it sounds ugly.
It's really ugly.
It sounds very ugly.
Okay, so now we glow stone it.
Now we glow stone it.
Alright.
Okay, I got us...
I need lamb chops.
I'm gonna throw away this meat too.
And then...
What did we wanna bring?
Snowmen.
No we don't.
No.
There's no point.
Snowmen doesn't...
There was a point.
Oh my gosh.
So the endermen don't come near us because the endermen don't like the snow.
That's important, right?
I don't think we have snow though.
We need silk touch.
We don't have that.
So this is our one life.
Water works better than snow.
Oh!
I have a bucket anyway.
I almost messed it up.
We can just make a water pool in the center.
We just bring two buckets.
One would be used as a water pool.
So we get bait the endermen.
We can like just put a pool.
There is a way to shovel.
We'll use a shovel to pick up snow and then we can turn the snowballs into cubes.
But...
If water is fine...
Yeah, let's just use water.
It's just easier.
Water bucket is just easier.
Make sure I have... Oh my god, there's so much sheep here.
I'm getting the sheep.
Goodbye sheep.
We need you to die so we can live.
This is what my power is for.
I got the glowstone.
Glow dust.
Let's see.
Chicken.
Oh my gosh, this blaze rod lasted forever.
That's awesome.
Yeah, you can make three potions I think.
That's what they said.
Yeah, but one...
I've only used it...
Okay, so one blaze rod turns into two powders and I've only used one powder this entire time.
Oh wait, that's...
That's a lot.
Wowee, we're learning so much about Minecraft from this challenge.
We're learning so much.
Wow.
Did you like participate in a competition and win?
How do you not know anything?
The competition has nothing to do with Minecraft.
It's just parkour and mini games.
And I played Valorant.
I somehow was able to play Valorant in Minecraft.
I don't know how, but I played Valorant in Minecraft.
Wow.
Okay.
And we have to do that competition again on Monday.
Not Monday, on Saturday.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
I got so offended, you guys.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
How did I get lost?
Okay, okay.
I'm looking at the coordinates right now.
I'm like wondering where I went.
I traveled so far.
Oh, we put pumpkin heads!
Pumpkin heads!
Pumpkin heads makes Enderman neutral.
So we wear pumpkin heads.
They won't...
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Nevermind.
Oh wait, does this count?
You guys, I have nothing left.
I have no dust powder.
No blaze powder left.
Heading back.
I think I'm heading back.
Guys, I'm lost.
Where did I go?
I don't know where I went.
I don't want to use a whole blaze powder.
You think it's fine?
Just for three potions, guys?
Is this where I went?
How did I go so far?
Are you not able to sleep?
I'm trying.
Oh my god.
Am I heading the right way?
Yes, I am.
I'm coming back.
I don't know.
I don't know how I got here.
I'm heading back now.
I'm heading back.
I see the tower.
I know where you are.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
I'm here.
Alright, let's sleep.
I got lots of meat for us.
Hello, boy.
Alright.
There's a creeper right over the way.
Oh, it's okay.
It's not like he's going to come over here and kill us.
Nah, he wouldn't do that.
He wouldn't do it.
That's such a piece of shit.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I have so much lamb.
I'm going to put the meat here.
And then...
Uh...
I'll put the raw meat here.
And try to find more meat for us.
Wait, where did my...
Guys, where did my...
Where did my...
Where did the thing underneath go?
What did I press?
What did I...
Oh, F1.
Wait, that's not F1?
It's not F1?
What did I...
What?
That's...
Why is F1...
Why is F1 that?
What?
Wait.
I pressed F1.
What are you talking about?
How do I...
Oh.
Oh, that's what I did.
No, I couldn't see my...
I couldn't see my thing for a while.
I was going crazy.
I couldn't see...
Yeah, I couldn't see my HUD.
I was trying to figure out how to unhud it.
Or hud it back.
Hud it back.
Okay.
I got it.
What else do we need, chat?
I'm going into the nether.
Get your quartz.
I'm farming more meat.
Okay.
What else do we need?
Follow my torches.
You'll find lots of quartz there.
Okay.
You got this, Min.
I'm getting us meat.
I'm back here once again.
We're back in hell.
We never thought we'd be back.
But here we are.
Back in hell.
I hate you.
We never thought we'd be back.
But here we are.
Okay, I'm following your torches.
Oh, here's some.
Okay.
I'm mining.
I got to level 30.
That's all you need.
Wait, when you reset, does mine also reset?
I don't think so, right?
That shouldn't be the case, right, everybody?
Like, you're...
Okay, so now I have to...
Alright, I can get...
I can reset it here.
No?
Okay, so...
Okay, that's good to know.
Alright, I have a lot of different types of meat for us, too.
Farmed a lot.
So I think...
I think we should have enough.
We should have enough for the dragon.
It's like KBBQ up in here.
Yeah, we have all different flavors.
All...
Different flavors and tastes.
And variety.
Exciting!
Alright, here we go.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming back with all the meat.
And I'm just gonna start burning them.
I'm gonna start burning them and then...
Oh my God, that's a skelly.
Oh my God.
Wait, how did you get to...
Did you get to...
I'm gonna die.
Mint!
I'm coming back!
I'm running back!
I'm running to the nether!
I killed him!
I killed the ghast!
He was low enough for me to kill him.
Okay, okay, that's good.
I'm still running over.
I'm not gonna die.
You got this.
Maybe I will die.
No, don't say that.
Don't ruin my portal, please.
Don't say that.
I want us to die at the end.
If we're gonna die, we have to die at least...
Make it to the end of dragon where we're gonna die.
That's where we're gonna die.
I'd rather it be there than anywhere else.
I can't leave.
I'm stuck in here and I have no food.
Yeah, because I can't get through the portal.
Or else he's gonna destroy it.
No!
Don't destroy the portal, please!
I can't run!
I'm heading over!
I don't think you can do anything...
Unless you have a...
Go, go, go!
Go through the portal!
Go through it!
I'm here!
Uh-oh.
Go through the portal.
You're fine.
I'm here.
Did you get through?
No, no, no.
I'm farming.
I'm gonna farm some quartz.
It's okay.
I'm here.
I'll protect.
I'll protect the portal.
I got another gas tier.
Lucky.
That's not a regen.
I can make...
I can make six more regens.
That's good.
Should we do?
Anymore quartz near us?
No, I didn't have any bows and arrows.
I just went in.
Raw dogging it, baby.
Go in.
So many fucking piglings.
Oh, I didn't get a thing.
Piglings.
They're everywhere.
I'm doing something very...
Oh, I can't do this.
I can't do this.
I can't.
Oh my god, there he is.
Nope.
Don't do that.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, okay.
Yes, I'm alright.
I'm alright.
I was fucking bobbing and weaving.
Bobbing and weaving him.
Do you need me to cover you?
No, I'm alright.
I'm alright.
I'm safe.
I made it through.
The gas doesn't know.
Okay, alright.
Gas is stupid, dumbass.
Stupid as hell.
Stupid.
Where's all the books?
I have them here.
And I'll put the lapis on the second chest.
I have lapis.
There was some more.
Okay.
Okay, um...
I'm just gonna kill wildlife.
Oh, I have infinity!
Wait, that's good!
I need level 30.
Wait, aren't you level 30?
I'm 28.
I used my levels to do another thing.
Oh, okay.
That's not good.
Let me see if I have anything you can cook.
Wait, if the thing...
Can you get XP from me?
Cooking meat?
Yeah, you can.
Okay, I put some stuff in there so you can grab the meat for...
What the hell is a bundle?
What do you mean?
I just looked at my...
Things I can create.
And what is a bundle?
I don't know.
Yeah, just get the stove for XP.
It can hold a mixed stack of...
What?
What is this?
Oh, extra storage?
Yeah!
Break the furnace for XP?
It's full.
How do I make it empty?
I'm gonna see if there's any animals I can kill.
Oh, I can kill the squids.
Yeah, you're right.
Wait, you can kill squids for XP?
Squids and fish...
You can kill anything for XP.
I'm gonna swim out.
I think we got all the quartz too at the...
We got all the quartz that are close to...
In the near area.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think the others are just way too dangerous for us to farm at that point.
I'm just gonna kill the animals.
It's true, because there's like skellies and gas in that area really badly.
Yeah.
I would advise not to go any further.
I farmed all the ones that were far, but like...
Not dangerous.
Cook the fish too.
Cook the fish.
Yeah, just cook any types of meat and stuff.
I cook the fish.
You cook the fish?
I wish I could kill the birds.
I wish I could just kill the birds that are flying up here.
I wish I could just...
I don't see any birds.
No, they exist!
They're there!
No, they're not.
There's no birds.
They're real!
They're real to me.
What does that mean?
It's a shared hallucination.
Oh, they're real to me.
They're real to me.
Yeah.
So is Santa Claus.
Oh, Santa Claus is real.
I know, he's real to me.
He's real to all of us.
Oh, it would be so sad if I died by drowning if that was the way I go.
That would just be really sad.
That would be so sad if that was the way I decided to go after everything I've been through.
I decided to just drown and put myself out of my misery.
That's a valiant way to go down, probably.
Oh, die.
Die, squid, die.
Your life is meaningless.
I'm going so fast.
We have to go back, it's almost night time.
Okay.
I'm killing the fish.
I'm killing the cows.
I'm gonna kill the cows.
And I'm gonna kill the chicken.
Kill the chicken.
Kill the cow.
Kill the koala.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna salad fingers these.
Salad fingers.
Oh no.
Sleep, sleep, sleep.
Oh yeah, check the furnace.
For XP.
I will, I have been sleep.
Okay.
Did you get enough XP?
No.
I have like nothing.
How much does it give you?
I'm still...
I'm not even halfway through 28.
Do we need all those enchantments?
Do we...
Do we really need everything?
Everybody.
Guys, do we really need...
If we stock up on all the potions...
Remember how I said we gotta farm all the redstone for XP?
I did.
I farmed as much as we could.
I know, I'm just saying.
I was at level 35.
Yeah, we have to have infinity at least on one of our bows though.
Yeah, I have power.
Do you have arrows?
I can give you some of the arrows I made.
If I have infinity, I only need one.
Oh, that's true.
Doesn't it...
Sometimes it runs out.
It's literally called infinity.
Wouldn't it like break?
Wait, really?
You're thinking of like the bow will break.
Oh!
Okay, yeah, I can give you one of the...
I'll give you one of my arrows.
Yeah, we do need anvil though to make it...
Yeah, there's an anvil.
I made an anvil already.
We have an anvil, everybody.
We're set.
Where's more coal that I can mine?
Just killing the wildlife.
Do horses give XP?
Oh, I don't think so.
Do horses...
There's a lot of horses.
I'm thinking about it.
Just kill one and test it for science.
No, because they hit back.
They fight back.
The other wildlife don't fight back.
They do.
They do give XP.
Yes!
Okay, they do.
They do.
I found a lot of lappers.
Oh my God.
Do armadillos give XP?
No, don't kill the armadillos.
Do they give XP?
Probably not.
Don't listen to me.
Do they give XP?
I'm gonna do it.
I don't need to know.
They do.
I'm fucking going in.
I'm going in.
I'm getting us meat for food.
I have so much meat right now.
Oh, there's a pillager right here.
Uh oh.
I'm gonna not look at him.
Where did I get that?
I'm not gonna look at him.
I'm fucking bloodthirsty right now.
I'll kill anything and everything except for the pillager.
Because I don't want to deal with that.
I'll kill anything.
Then let's start the raid.
Remember, you get the potion now.
Oh, okay.
I'll just go kill him then.
Yeah, kill him.
Who cares about his measly little life?
He's a pathetic man.
Woah.
Pathetic little pillager guy.
Alright.
I guess I'll go kill him now.
He's a pathetic little guy.
Did he disappear?
Where did he go?
He heard you.
He's afraid of me.
He actually heard you.
He despawned.
He actually despawned.
He's like, nah.
He's like, nah, F that.
I'm out.
Oh my god.
Never mess with me, little pillager man.
He ran away so fast.
Oh my god.
There's lots of dripstone in here.
He actually disappeared.
I was ready.
That's my power.
He got scared.
Oh, baby.
Oh, baby man.
Do donkeys give...
It doesn't matter, we can still kill him.
Kill, kill, kill.
Kill all of them.
This was what my power was for.
I'm coming back.
I'll go back too.
Oh, more meat.
Give me all my meat, please.
Give me all these deaths.
Death to the wildlife.
Might as well go extinct in this world.
Yeah, if we're gonna go extinct, the wildlife too.
Yeah, if we're gonna suffer, they all suffer.
They all suffer.
Do my dogs...
Oh my god.
Would you really?
If you were so desperate for XP, would you kill your friend?
Do my dogs give...
Do my...
Does Doki give XP?
Does he give XP?
Does he?
Your laugh is getting more and more maniacal as you...
No, I don't wanna waste a level.
I don't wanna waste a level.
I was gonna name one of them.
I was gonna name one of them dad and then look him in the eye and ask, do you give XP?
Do you give XP?
That's kinda raw, man.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna check the Lulu laugh.
Do you give XP?
Do you?
Okay, um...
I need...
I need to...
You can take the burning and the me and stuff for the...
I know, I've been taking it.
Yeah, just take it.
You can have it.
I'm still...
I'm not even at level 29 though.
Uh...
I know, it's painful.
Can you pass me a book?
Oh wait, no, never mind.
There's more books here.
I'm just gonna...
I'm resetting.
I need to reset one.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot to bring a lapis.
Wait, you have all the lapis?
Oh no, the lapis is here.
No, there's lots of lapis in there.
Time to go to the jungle.
The rainy jungle.
Blast?
Why does it keep giving me...
I'm just gonna get protection 2.
I'm just...
Guys, I'm just gonna get protection 2.
Like, I...
There's no...
There's only blast protection.
Guys, this is it.
This is the best I can do.
I can't...
Protection 2 is 5.
Protection 2...
Don't piss me off.
You look like you...
are just enough EXP.
Okay.
Someone said that this song has gotten more and more sad as the time goes on.
What are you playing?
No, the lion sleeps at night.
The more we sing that song, the sadder it becomes.
I know, I was really excited about it.
The lion sleeps at night.
The lion...
Why is there no coal?
No chicken?
Are you talking about for farming?
I was gonna say...
There's a lot of coal in the...
What else do you need?
My arm is fully ready.
I still need my helmet and my pants.
And then I was gonna get the infinity on the book.
Oh, wait.
What did you put on your bow then?
No, I don't need it.
You can have infinity.
And then...
My bow is ready with power.
I already have power on my bow.
You can put infinity on it too.
No, it's fine.
I don't need it.
I actually don't need it.
I have enough arrows.
I have 45, so it's fine.
I have 45.
I have 45 normal arrows and then 20 spectral arrows.
Uh, 20...
20 plus...
Yeah, but it's just arrows.
That's fine.
I don't need another infinity.
I think we should just go with whatever.
Try to level up all your stuff.
And then...
Like, all your armor, because I'm done, I think.
I'm done.
Sorry, kid.
Sorry, you have no mom anymore.
I'm so sorry.
Guys, it's fine.
Guys, believe.
Believe.
Believe in this.
Guys, believe.
Believe.
I've done this before.
Guys, believe.
I think I once soloed the ender dragon.
Yeah, I think you did, actually.
I remember.
I feel like I did that.
But I had, like, way better stuff.
That's true.
Didn't you have netherite stuff?
Oh, I also have to...
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna...
Oh, God.
I'm not...
I'm kind of lost.
Oh, no.
The sun's coming down.
Okay, coordinates are...
I can't look at it yet, because I'm in bed.
Oh, I see it.
Never mind.
I'm coming.
No, you got the infinity, right?
You already got it on your own.
No, I haven't put it on yet, but I will...
Yeah.
Okay, I'm...
I'm coming to bed.
I'm almost there.
I lit up the area a little bit, so it should be, like, not so dangerous.
I'm on my way.
I'm sleeping.
I'm eeping.
My chat doesn't...
My chat doesn't believe.
They're like, yeah, you're cooked, but you might win.
What the hell?
This is our one run!
This is literally our one run!
Why don't you believe?
Why don't you believe in us?
We have one run!
You have to believe in us.
Please believe in us.
We have no faith.
We really need this win.
Okay, I'm gonna put, like, trash stuff in my inventory that I don't need.
Okay, I need the torch.
I need this.
I don't need the gold helmet anymore.
I don't... I'm gonna grab wood just in case.
I don't need... I'll grab this just in case too.
And then get the bed.
Get this out of here.
Get the wood rid of this.
We need coal.
We don't need this.
We have this.
This is fine.
We don't need this.
Have you guys found the end portal?
We're gonna do that the moment we finish kidding ourselves up!
We're gonna get that into that soon.
I'm gonna make them.
I'm gonna make the end pearl things into the...
Okay, I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 beds.
That's enough beds.
Oh, you should make that.
Actually, you're right.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6... I have 7 beds.
I have 7 beds.
I don't think... I think you need, like, 20... Isn't that, like, a ton of beds, you guys?
Oh my gosh.
We have these two beds.
8, 9.
We have 9 beds.
It's okay.
We'll just do it with our...
Do I need extra iron or no?
Wait, I can make iron ingot nuggets.
No, I don't have... Okay.
I think I have enough for... Do I have enough for...
Okay, 1.
How many for buckets?
We're already an hour in.
I need 3.
Okay, so...
I need 2 more.
I need...
Wait.
Oh no.
I don't have enough.
I only have one bucket.
Do you have a bucket on you?
Yeah, I have one bucket.
Okay, we both have a bucket.
So it should be fine.
I think we need more.
Don't we need to... Well...
We need to, like, cover the ground with water.
That's our one bucket for.
That's not gonna cover the whole ground.
We don't have enough iron.
We don't...
We actually don't have enough iron.
Unless I swim.
Time to find iron.
Yeah, a 2x2 infinite water.
Will that work?
Wait, we need 4 buckets of water then, right?
We need 4 buckets of water to make the 2x2.
I just need 2?
Oh, we both have 2.
Yeah, we both have 2.
We just need to make sure we don't fuck up the infinite water source.
Alright, that's a fucking... We only have one!
We only have one!
One bucket?
No, we have 2.
I mean, we only have one chance for this.
Yeah.
And if we don't succeed, people are gonna see the two VODs and be like, oh, of course they made it.
They're not gonna watch to the end, right?
They're not gonna...
We could just cut it and say that we had a streaming issue.
But we didn't.
Take a screenshot on Google.
Yeah, yeah.
We could photoshop our characters and that.
We can hire someone on Fiverr to repeat it with our skins.
Alright.
We just put in the new video.
Which is like, well, but we managed to record it.
We managed to record the final...
The final fight.
Guys, and then we upload it as a video and then nobody will know.
How would they know?
So we need iron.
I'm gonna go look for some more coal too so I can... I need to just get a little bit more level.
How much more levels do you need?
One, but I'm at 29.
29.
But like...
At the lower end, 29?
Did you grab everything for cooking?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm grabbing this copper then so I can cook it for you.
You can just grab the stuff.
Okay.
I'm searching.
Wait, so do you think I shouldn't get infinity then?
No, you should get infinity.
I think infinity is more important.
Okay, I'll get infinity.
So then I can give you the arrow and then you do the infinity stuff.
Okay, I'll do infinity.
And I'll just do like a second level for my...
for my helmet and my pants.
And then we can...
We can head off into the...
You know, if we lose this run and we do it again, I will not be surprised if it's easier.
I wouldn't.
I feel like...
If we were in a new seed...
If we were in the bad end of the stick and all that.
I think we just got the worst seed possible.
I think so too.
Maybe we should just die right now and restart with a new seed.
We're gonna die.
At least die at the dragon.
At that point, let's just go find the stronghold.
In the little stronghold.
Let's just find the stronghold at that point.
Like, fuck getting anything else.
Why is there nothing around here?
This area is so...
We bring the enchantment table and the books with us to the stronghold.
And then we can get XP at the stronghold.
Oh, true.
Yeah.
Okay, we can do that.
Just grab everything that we're gonna bring to the...
So are we picking up shop?
We're packing up shop.
This is it.
This is the final hour.
Wait, don't you need a silk touch to take out the...
Take out what?
The enchantment table.
Wait, really?
You need silk touch?
Wait, if you break the enchantment table, you reset the enchantments?
Yeah, lose infinity.
Okay, let's just make a new enchantment table.
I have enough diamonds.
Alright, saying goodbye to...
Wait, what do we need for enchantment tables?
We need...
We also need the bookshelf.
Three obsidian... Yeah, bookshelves we can remake easily.
Okay, we just get more book...
I mean, more wood.
Okay.
I remember Kai's be taking...
Oh, it was not five days.
It was much longer than five days.
I remember I remember watching that stream.
I remember it taking much longer.
Oh yeah, there's a library in the stronghold.
Oh, I can mine it?
People are saying I can break the enchantment table.
You can?
People said don't.
You can mine it, but I don't have silk touch.
Oh, I guess you can mine it.
Oh, just maybe people are... Someone says don't.
Others say don't.
Some says yes.
Get infinity first before... Wait, she doesn't have the levels.
They're saying you can mine it, but oh yeah, when you get rid of it, I will get...
Oh, you don't have your infinity.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're right.
Okay, okay.
What do we do?
You need one level, right?
Okay, I'll put stuff in the...
How much more from that one level?
I'm going back into the nether.
No, don't do it.
No, it's too... Don't do it.
It's too risky.
How much more do you need?
I need a lot.
You need a lot?
A lot, a lot.
How much is a lot, a lot?
I think I need to go back and I'm going in.
No!
Wait, can you come...
Wait, can you come with and build a wall, right?
So that the gas spawns by the...
I'll build a house around it, but like, in a sec, I need stuff.
I'm gonna get dirt.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
You can go in first and then out, like, because you'll be walking away from it, right?
Did I put the shovel?
Okay, I'm gonna go grab dirt and then build stuff around it.
I think I see some quartz.
Oh, shit.
There's already a gas.
Oh, there's already a gas.
I'm grabbing dirt.
I'm grabbing dirt as fast as I can.
I can't use the wood, guys.
The wood is for something else I'm trying to make.
The wood is for something else I'm trying to make right now.
Okay.
I'm digging, like, kind of a hole for me, so that...
How much dirt did I get?
Oh, my pickaxe just broke.
Oh, no.
Okay, I'm coming in.
I'm giving you my pickaxe.
Okay.
Um, you can find me in a hole.
Here, this way.
Do you see me?
Give me a sec.
I'm building the house first.
I think maybe he despawned.
I don't hear him anymore.
I don't hear him either.
Can I have your pickaxe?
Yeah, just give me a sec.
I'm building our little house.
Yep.
Okay.
That works, yeah.
Thank you.
Just for a moment.
Alright, I'm grabbing more dirt.
I'm just gonna sleep through this night, too.
Oh, my god.
I do hear still the gas.
I hear it.
I know.
I'm grabbing more stuff for the house.
I'm mining the dirt.
I ran out of dirt.
Okay, I'm almost halfway.
Where is he?
I'm just gonna get 40 and then go back in.
Cobblestones.
I can't get cobblestones.
I don't have cobblestone.
I don't have my pickaxe anymore.
And we don't have iron.
Oh, god.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Please despawn.
You ugly...
Please despawn!
Okay, he might despawn now.
He might despawn now.
Oh, my god.
I'm in my little hole.
I'm in my hole.
There was one more quartz area that I can think I can get to.
Is he gone?
No, he's not gone.
I don't know.
Just stay in your little hole.
You know what?
I'm just gonna mine.
I'm just gonna strip mine here.
And then maybe I'll hit quartz safely.
Perhaps.
I'm gonna mine some more dirt for us.
Oh, my god.
I just gotta get a few...
I just gotta get a few more experience, guys.
It's just almost there.
Did you get quartz?
Don't burn!
I'm trying not to.
Very nice.
Nice.
Alright, I'm going to the portal and see if he's there.
I think he is.
Don't say that.
I'm being as safe as I possibly can.
Oh!
So close to 30?
So close?
Oh, my god.
I'm so close to level 30.
There you go.
I feel a little bit more safe now.
Oh, more quartz.
Okay.
There we go.
We're a little safer now.
I made...
I made a little hut.
I got to level 30.
I can do infinity now.
Yeah!
I'm gonna put torches for you so you know this is where we live.
Okay.
I think I know, but...
Alright, here you go.
Okay.
There's all the torches.
There's all the torches in the world!
I wish I was farming quartz.
Rich in quartz.
I wish we...
I wish we died earlier.
I don't know.
I wish we...
I wish we didn't stayed in this seed.
I know.
Me too.
I wish we died in the very beginning of the nether.
Me too!
It would be so long from now.
Okay, I'm back.
Oh, where's your pickaxe?
You know what I also wish?
I wish we got out of the mines earlier.
I wish we got...
Do you regret what you did in the mines?
I regret this entire event.
I regret everything.
Wait, why can't I do infinity?
Oh, three lapis.
Oh, that's why.
Okay.
Okay, I got infinity.
Alright, time to break.
I'll break it now.
I'm breaking it.
Okay.
I got the enchanting table and then I'm gonna grab the bookcases too.
Name it.
No, my levels are precious.
I'm not gonna waste a single level on a name.
His name is Bo.
I'm gonna remake the bookshelf.
I think...
I really think, Doki, this bow would be better with you since it's a powerful bow.
Mine has power 4.
And mine has unbreaking 3 also.
Only unbreaking 3?
What's yours unbreaking?
Mine has power 4.
Mine has power 4, unbreaking 3 and infinity.
Oh, okay.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
I didn't realize you have all those.
One and done?
Oh my god.
This is embarrassing.
I don't want this thing.
What the hell?
Why is it embarrassing?
Here's your fucking arrows.
Oh, thank you.
You have arrows?
Yeah, I have one arrow.
Do you want spectral arrows too?
No, no, it's okay.
Why is it...
No, we can't combine the bows, guys.
Because Smit needs the bows too.
She needs the bows as well.
She needs...
I need the bows.
She's telling us to combine the bows.
What's the big use?
They're trying to sabotage us.
Alright, did you make the eye of ender?
Yeah.
Don't do the bed strap, because it's not good and only for speedrunners.
I've done the bed strap before.
You have?
Yeah, we've done it together in that room we had.
I didn't do it.
I don't think.
No, I didn't do it.
Didn't we do it?
I thought I did.
No, I don't think so.
Pretty sure.
It could kill us.
Yeah, that's what I'm feeling.
Okay, I'll get rid of the beds.
Fine.
I'll get rid of them.
Oh, you guys are scared.
You guys, I gave away my infinity bow.
That's why I have all the arrows.
I gave...
Oh, man.
I think some people are more tired than me.
Alright, I'm gonna...
Alright, let me... I'm just making...
Okay, bookshelf.
I'm just remaking the shelves for us.
Not enough wood?
Do you have wood or no?
Not a lot of wood.
Okay, I'll just farm the last trees here.
And then we'll head over.
We'll head over.
Mint, please.
It's 440.
It's 540 for me.
Sun's almost up, guys.
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's see.
Wood.
I can't do much more.
That's why we have the last row.
I'm almost done, but I love it.
Me too.
I thought we'd be at the dragon by now.
I don't know why we're still here.
Okay, then let's go.
I didn't realize...
I didn't realize how underleveled we were.
I thought we leveled up.
I told you, I told you.
You had the same amount of...
I know, but I told you we needed so so many.
There were so many quartz that we didn't pick up.
We didn't...
Don't forget the potion.
Why didn't the chat tell us to pick up the quartz?
Yeah, why didn't the chat tell us?
You guys should have been saying, Hey, you need more levels.
Get the quartz.
Yeah, get more of the quartz.
Get more of the quartz.
Get more of them.
You should have said get more of the quartz.
Yeah, you should have said get more of the quartz.
If you said get more of the quartz, I would have got more of the quartz.
Now they're blaming us.
We need the quartz for the...
We need the quartz for that.
Chat, why didn't you get those?
I didn't know.
Hey, chat.
Yeah, chat.
Why didn't you tell us about the quartz, chat?
Do you think my sword will last, you guys?
I think mine will.
Okay, what potions did I get?
Potion of regeneration.
You made so many.
Yeah.
You don't get all of them.
Half and half.
You said half.
That's not half.
I got 2, 4, 5 for regen.
And 2, 4, 4 for slow falling.
Yeah.
It's half.
It's literally half.
What the fuck are you talking about?
You have 5 for both.
And I have 4.
I have 2, 4, 5 for regen.
And then 2, 4 for slow falling.
Okay, so you're giving me slow...
Okay, I get it.
Should we just...
Should I make more?
No, I think we're fine.
It's not gonna take us that long.
It's 4 minutes each.
We're not gonna take 30 minutes to kill this dragon.
We either die within 10 minutes...
or we do something in 10 minutes.
It's one or the other.
We die in 10 minutes.
Okay, we gotta sleep in the bed before we fucking...
Yeah, we gotta sleep in the bed.
Netherrack, he'll like...
He'll blow it up, right?
What?
Someone just said...
This message got delayed.
Pick up the quartz.
Why didn't we pick up the quartz?
We were trapped in the nether for 4 hours.
Imagine how fucked up we would be.
We would have been like level 7.
We would have been like level 70.
I can't believe we didn't pick it up.
I'm gonna grab the lapis.
I got some lapis.
I'm gonna grab netherrack for like when we...
When we need to climb.
Did you grab the ender pearl and eye of ender stuff?
Yeah, I have all that.
I'm gonna grab your potions.
Yeah, I know.
I'm making space.
I'm gonna bring the brewing stand just in case.
Oh, pickaxe?
Yeah, I need that.
You have a lot of wood, right?
I have 40.
We can grab some while we're fucking heading over to the stronghold wherever it is.
Okay, that's it.
We're just gonna be so many trees.
Okay, I'll get rid of that and that.
Hold on guys, sorry.
I'm putting stuff away.
I'm making stuff.
Let's see.
Oh wait, I'll take my sticks.
I'll grab blocks while we're on the way, chat.
There's so many blocks ahead of us.
We can grab blocks while we're going there.
There we go, I got water.
Oh, you got all the food?
We gotta get the food.
I got 44.
I think you have the chicken, right?
I got the beefs and the chickens.
I had pork chop and mutton.
So we can split that.
You take those, I take the others.
Take the beds.
There's so much they can do to prepare.
There's so little time left in our bodies.
Our bodies are gonna expire soon.
We don't have...
We don't have the time to prep more.
I'm taking the melons until the fight.
This is the two different types of tiredness from Min and I.
Min is the...
I'm gonna fucking pass out.
I am hysterical and I'm delusional right now.
I'm a type of tired.
I'm the Lulu at the moment.
Two types of tiredness from us.
We don't need the ender chest.
We don't need it.
They're telling us we need an ender chest?
It's for more room, but we don't.
We don't need it.
We're fine.
We do need...
I have one other shield.
I actually have two shields.
Maybe I'll be okay.
Um, I do...
Can I put something in my little bundle?
Can I put...
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, I can put the food in the bundle.
Oh, that's smart.
Oh, it's full.
This thing sucks.
Maybe we should have made an ender chest.
Do we have enough ender pearls for an ender chest, though?
That's the thing.
No, we need to save all eyes of ender.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm missing one slow-falling...
You know what?
Fine.
Go away, stick.
Actually, I'm gonna make...
Wait.
Even if I make a pickaxe, I can't take it.
We need these pearls, you guys.
We need these for...
We need them.
We'll make the chest when...
I mean, it wouldn't matter by then when we're there.
When we fight.
How do I take stuff out?
Oh, no.
Only one.
Nope.
No, I'm taking the...
You guys, we're remaking the enchantment table.
So when we...
Yeah, I have everything.
I have the enchantment table and I have 15 bookshelves.
And I have lapis lazuli.
Actually, I'll get books there.
Oh, that's true.
I already made 15.
It's fine.
It's in my pocket.
I feel like we just find...
Straight up find the fucking thing.
And then put the pearls in there.
And then we call it.
And then we go in there.
We either kill the dragon or we die.
And then we try this again in another day.
Why do people keep saying the pearls?
I'm so confused.
I have all the pearls.
This is all the pearls.
How many more pearls do we need?
Oh, wait, there's so many more in here.
I didn't even notice them.
Wait, hold on.
The ones that I gave?
Yeah, those are the ones I put down there.
Oh, I didn't even see.
Okay, hold on.
I need to make way more things.
Hold on.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I didn't even see these.
I put them in the beginning.
I told you.
I didn't see them.
It's alright.
We've lost our minds.
And those people who are like, you gotta spend more time.
No, we've...
We've spent enough.
We've...
We've spent enough, guys.
Oh, I didn't know there was more.
If we...
If we don't make it this run, we'll try again another time.
We'll do the stream earlier.
I'm not gonna bring the brewing.
We'll do the stream in the morning instead.
I think if we didn't...
No, I'm not...
No, I'm not meant tomorrow.
I'm not meant...
I meant like another time.
In the future.
We'll try again.
We'll try again in the future.
Alright.
I need to make a pickaxe now.
Oh, I can't.
I'm gonna make a diamond one.
You have enough?
Yeah, I think so.
Where'd my sticks go?
I have my sticks.
No, guys, we cannot...
We're not gonna do it in Atlanta.
Guys, we're...
We have other things to do.
They're like, hey, how about you, like, do a whole concert and then also stream for 24 hours?
That'd be like super cool.
It'll be so fun.
Oh my god.
Like, no, but you have experience now with this.
It won't be that bad.
Oh my god.
That's the funniest thing ever.
We learned so much from this one playthrough.
Are you not bringing the bed?
No, they keep telling us that we're gonna die.
Then it's fine.
We don't need the bed.
You might need the bed to head over there, maybe.
Yeah, bring a bed to sleep.
Alright, I'm throwing away my one iron.
Alright, I'm ready.
Throw it up into the air and say I don't care.
I don't care.
I'm throwing the eye of ender in the air.
I'm going up in the air, I'm going up, I'm going up high.
I'm throwing it in the air.
Tell the world we don't care.
Are you gonna say bye to your dads or whatever?
What?
Oh, oh shit.
My dogs, get over here.
I almost forgot you guys existed.
I fucking thought you guys died because I was XP crazy.
Okay.
Throw it in the air.
Wait, do I just throw it or do I...
How do I do this?
Because sometimes it doesn't break.
You throw it in the air.
Throw it in the air and tell the world you don't care.
Oh, this way.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, it didn't break.
Grab it.
Well, I don't have space.
You gotta grab it.
Okay, I'll grab it.
Alright.
Let's go.
Okay, we're going.
Yup, let's go.
I guess.
Let's go.
I roll to here and then you throw it in the air.
Oh, that's it.
Oh, okay.
Goodbye, peepee tower.
Goodbye.
Do you really need to be up top while you throw it?
Can you just throw it here?
No, it's better to throw it up in a high place.
Throw it in the air.
And tell the world you don't care.
Where are you?
I'm here.
Someone says go longer.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Alright, we'll go longer after this one.
No!
Oh, it's this way.
Well, thank god I didn't go longer.
Oh, it's in the tree.
Goddammit.
Is it this way?
Right here?
Gotta get out of the tree.
Yeah, it's like a diagonal.
It's like this way.
That's a new dog.
I told you there were dogs over here.
Come on, come on.
Don't get distracted.
I'm going.
I'm fucking...
I'm heading over.
We're going.
They actually passed over the stronghold on the way back from the long nether trip.
How would we know that?
How do you know that?
Why did no one said anything?
Why did no one super daka super this and be like, that's the stronghold!
I feel like we get $100 if we pass by the stronghold.
I feel...
Seed checker?
They don't know the seed?
Hey, where are you?
They don't know the seed!
I never showed the seed!
Where did you go?
I'm walking in the...
Come on.
I thought I was walking the right direction.
Wait, give me a sec.
Stay where you are.
Give me your coordinates.
I'm making a tower.
I went in the other direction.
We went back towards home!
We already went and said goodbye.
It's so awkward.
I'm sorry.
Give me your coordinates.
Apparently while I had my coordinates I passed by the stronghold because of the bio.
What's your coordinates?
They saw the bio!
Why did you get this?
Negative 421 1899 421 What?
Just sleep.
You didn't ask!
Oh my god.
This is the most Metal Gear ass.
Thank you.
Thank you, Plissken.
Snake Plissken.
What's your number again?
422 421 918 97 1897 This is where I fucked up.
Don't say what a thrill!
That's the wrong game!
I see you.
Keep going straight.
I'm here now.
You see me?
I went the wrong way.
I thought I saw the right way but I didn't see the right way.
I'm watching out for the hole now.
I'm eating my bread.
Wait, so then...
Chat, for people who noticed and just decided not to say anything.
How far away was it?
This is far.
At what point was it there?
We traveled 10,000 plus.
I'm already hungry.
I have lots of bread.
I left my...
Oh no, my watermelons are in the bundle.
Wait, hold on.
How do I get the watermelons out?
I'm trying to eat the watermelon.
After you're done with the watermelon I have bread, which might be more...
Someone just said no help.
This is ridiculous.
We've been through so much.
At this point, don't you feel anything for us?
Don't you feel compassion at that point?
Or any sense of human decency?
I can't believe...
Should I throw one here?
No help.
Chat's like...
It's the most...
It's the one thing I've always wanted to ban from my chat.
It's the fucking no help.
It makes me want to pull out my hair.
Do you want me to become bald?
I will become bald.
They'll enjoy it.
No, don't encourage it.
They'll just enjoy it so much.
I'm bald now.
I never said no.
Don't backseat.
I am one of the few VTubers out there that embraces backseating.
I will not progress if I don't get backseated.
You can't say that about me.
I am all about backseating.
Someone just super chat me.
They said every Minecraft world has 128 strongholds.
You might find a closer one.
Okay.
Thank you for the hope.
That's some real hope.
That's a helper.
That's a good helper.
Santa's little helper.
Thank you, little helper.
Thank you, Daven.
It's the same direction.
We just gotta keep going.
Okay.
Here we go.
Help.
I'll wait for you.
I'm right behind you.
I do have to pee though.
Alright.
Help.
Let me know when we should do the eye.
I'm gonna...
Do you have blocks?
I don't have any.
Oh my god.
Your dogs are pushing me.
Or you're pushing me.
I'm behind.
Do you have blocks?
I didn't bring blocks.
I do.
I'll just use some dirt.
Oh wait.
I don't have any room.
Um...
I have to get rid of cobblers.
You can just re-mine it after.
Just re-mine it here.
They'll fall.
I don't care.
Then what's the point of re-mining it?
They have no names.
Get your blocks.
No, I'm not talking about the dogs will fall.
I'm talking about the blocks will fall.
Get the blocks.
I can't.
Do you have a boat?
Yeah.
Yes, help.
Oh, wait.
I didn't mean to.
Get off the boat and I can get on it.
And then you can go with the eye of Ender out there.
And then the world will be a beautiful place.
What if I just...
kept going?
Alright.
Just keep going.
What if I just kept going?
Alright.
I think we can go to that area and then throw the eye, right?
Would that be fine?
Should we just keep going?
I don't know how many we have to do before we throw the eye in the air.
I don't know either.
You've done this before.
You've done this so many times.
I've done this two times.
That's two more than me.
That's...
Give me some...
Give me a little bit of a credit.
That's only two times.
That's two more than me.
That doesn't matter.
That's what I'm saying.
Okay, are you ready to throw it up?
In the water?
Just throw it up.
To our left.
Okay.
I'm going to the left.
To the left.
All my brain cells in a box to the left.
I think I might know y'all.
Yeah.
Three steps next time.
This is not...
My dog came over.
I'm sorry.
I know.
I know you're like, why are you still here?
Where is he?
He's like underneath my...
Oh my gosh.
No, not the...
Why did you do that?
Oh, your actual dog.
Yeah, my actual...
Okay.
Where does the eye of Ender tell you?
What does the eyes say?
Where's your Minecraft dogs?
Where are they?
I don't... It's fine.
It's fine.
Eye of Ender.
Tell us where you are.
That way.
Oh, it's alive.
Oh, it hasn't broken.
Nice.
Has it been... Has this been the same one?
Yeah.
This entire time?
Wait, where'd it go?
Where'd it go?
Why don't these things fucking flow, man?
I see it.
It's on me.
I got it.
Okay.
It's fine.
I got it.
This way, right?
Yeah.
Am I going the right way?
I already forgot.
Yeah, you're going the right way.
Tell if you're joking or not.
I can't.
No, I actually don't know.
I actually... No, no.
I'm talking about someone in chat.
Okay, okay.
I'm throwing the Eye of...
Eye to you.
Right here.
Oh, okay.
I'll throw it right here.
Oh, oh.
I'm still in the boat.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm breaking the boat because I only have one...
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Up we go.
Guys, you should buy the concert tickets, guys.
It's just the same fun experience.
What if we did this at the concert?
What if we did this, guys?
If you buy our tickets, we'll do this at the concert.
We're just gonna watch...
You can watch us play Minecraft.
We're just playing Minecraft in 3D.
In 3D.
Buy the tickets and watch us play.
Watch us play in 3D.
Watch it, but only if...
If only if the concert sells out.
Where'd you go?
I'm over here.
Alright.
Only the tickets sold out, then we'll do it.
It'll be the longest concert ever.
And then...
We'll get a world record.
If the venue kicks us out, we're gonna...
We're gonna take us to another venue.
And we're gonna keep doing it.
We're gonna...
We're just gonna keep going.
Until we...
Only if the concert sells out, though.
We won't do it.
Every single ticket has to be gone.
If you want us to play Minecraft in 3D...
For 24 hours straight.
No, don't say that.
Don't say that.
Well, is that not gonna be when we do the challenge?
We're gonna do the challenge all over again.
Do you really think this is gonna take us 24 hours?
Do you really?
Where did you go?
Oh, you're here.
Should we throw it?
Yeah, I'll throw it at the edge of this.
I told you to do that.
Alright, fucking buy every ticket.
Oh my god, that scared me.
That's fine.
I have lots of...
Oh my god.
I need to make sure I stop falling.
Alright.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Oh, what?
What?
We passed it.
Wait, that means it's close.
Oh my god, I'm waking up.
I'm waking up.
Okay, we go to that land and then we throw the eye again.
Because we didn't walk that far.
We didn't walk that far this time.
Where did you go?
Okay, then we throw it here.
Because I know we didn't walk that far compared to the other one.
Oh my god, oh my god, everybody.
Oh my god, oh my god.
This hopium.
This hopium is right here.
Get the guests on it too.
Everybody gets to play.
Alright, let's maybe sleep first.
It'll be a morning surprise.
It'll be a...
Good morning.
Come on.
Thank god.
Alright.
Throw it.
Throw it in the sky.
I'm gonna get the coal real quick.
I'm obsessed with mining coal.
It says beach.
Don't we have to be...
In the...
Don't we...
Have to be like...
I don't know.
They said we passed it by.
We passed two strongholds because of our coordinates.
I don't know what to believe anymore.
Well, that's fine.
Of course, we're maybe gonna pass something.
Alright.
Throw!
Over there.
Is it in the water?
Uh-oh.
What?
Looking at my biome.
Wait.
Go away.
It's back here?
Is that what it said?
Hold on, I'm trying...
Let's do it on the mountain.
On the mountain?
All the way there?
No.
Because over here...
It brought us back this way.
No, because we were all the way down.
We walked further.
No, I threw it right there.
In the knot.
Should we throw it one more time then?
Yeah, I'm gonna try here.
Huh?
Is it right below us?
Is it in the water?
Okay, I'm gonna go to the other side.
Right here on this hilltop and try now.
Okay.
Please, God, no.
Please be kind to us.
We've been through so much.
We've been through a lot.
Oh, no!
It's down there.
Oh, no, it didn't break.
Wow, this thing is indestructible.
It's awesome.
This is the worst seed.
This is the worst seed ever.
This is actually the worst seed.
This is actually...
It's the worst seed we've ever had.
Okay.
We can probably dig a...
Get doors.
I'm gonna make a door.
We can probably dig...
Like a... What's it called?
A staircase from like...
From the land.
And it should be okay, maybe.
Okay, I got a door.
Like, what if we dig down from here and then just...
I got a door.
Here, right?
It was here, right?
About, yeah, I think.
There we go.
I'm ready to dig down.
Where did you go?
Oh, okay.
Alright, dig down.
I'm ready.
Oh my god.
I'll wait for you.
I gave it back to you.
I know.
Where did my door go?
Okay, there we go.
Just know the water's gonna go inside.
So you gotta keep digging.
You gotta keep digging.
I fucked up my door.
I fucked it up!
What do you mean you...
What did you do?
Okay.
Alright, come down.
Okay, I'm coming.
Alright.
I don't know how to do this.
Just do a staircase down.
Like a spiral staircase down, I think.
What are we at?
40?
Alright, here we go.
Where's my pickaxe?
Alright.
Oopsie, I just...
Oh, my bad.
That's fine, watch this.
There we go.
Okay, perfect.
Oh, I fucked it up too.
Oh my god.
Hold on.
Do you have the other door?
I have the other door.
Wait, shoot, that's not how that works.
You have to put it down here.
Give me the door, give me the door.
Okay, hold on, I'm getting it.
I gotta get it with my hands.
Oh, here, I am here.
Alright, pass me the door.
I gave it to you.
Alright.
Wait, I hear it.
You hear what?
No, that's my music.
Here we go.
I don't know how this works, how do we do this?
How do we dig?
Are we doing it correctly?
Is this the stronghold area?
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm...
Am I heading correctly to the stronghold?
Am I...
I've never done the stronghold before.
I'm just digging.
I've never done stronghold before.
Just dig down?
Okay, just dig down.
Yeah, just do what you're doing.
Just a little spiral staircase kind of thing.
Just keep going.
Keep going down, I guess.
Yeah, just keep going.
Keep going down.
We'll get there eventually.
What if we go past it?
I don't know.
I can't tell.
I don't think we will.
I need iron.
We need iron?
I'll grab some just in case.
Okay.
You'll know when you get to it, though.
Did we miss it?
What if we missed it?
They're usually pretty deep, right?
It's a cave.
We're at a cave.
Oh, but it's water.
Yeah, this isn't...
What is it?
This is not it.
I'm exploring a little.
Oh gosh.
Making another spiral staircase?
Come back, come back, come back.
I'm trying to find...
Come back, come back.
I'm trying to find you.
That's just water.
Maybe we should go make some more doors.
That's still water!
Can you set down a...
cooking table?
Yeah, I can.
I'll make some more doors.
Here.
Why is there more water under the water?
Wait, where are you?
Oh, you're over here.
Okay.
Why is there so much water?
Why is there...
Why is there so much...
I don't understand.
Why is it just water?
Why is this the worst seat out there?
I don't...
I don't understand.
Like, is there anything that's not just water?
Water?
Like, it's water!
Oh my God, it's a cave within water!
Is that it?
What did you see?
I don't know what I just saw.
You would know if you saw it.
It's like a different block.
There's a different block right there.
No...
It's not a...
It's a normal block.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, it's hiding.
I hear a zombie.
Oh, shit.
How is it more submerged in water?
It could be...
A zombie.
Oh, hi.
Hello.
It could be a...
It could be...
A zombie that's in the...
Maybe?
This is...
This is the worst fortress.
Ever.
I'm gonna start building there.
Okay, and then...
There you go.
I'm in the Minecraft river.
I closed it off a little bit for you.
Throw a pearl?
Would it work if I...
There's more water?
There's more water.
Oh my...
But there has to be an area.
Use an eye to redirect?
What was that eerie noise?
That's just usually when there's a cave around.
Okay, I'm gonna throw an eye.
Come here, Doki.
I'm gonna do it right here.
I'm watching.
I'm gonna do it...
So we have some space.
Alright.
Eye!
Go!
What the fuck?
Where's it going?
I don't know.
Where did it go?
Where did your fucking eye go?
I don't know.
It's the other way.
Where did it go?
It went this way.
It went right over here.
We gotta go this way instead.
We grabbed the crafting table.
Did you grab the crafting table?
I got it, I got it.
Which way did it go?
It went that way?
It went this way.
Okay, I'm gonna mine this way then.
Where are you mining at?
I'm mining this way, the way you told me to go.
Oh yeah, that's good.
Okay,
nice.
There we go.
Yeah, this pearl is awesome.
Wait, is this the same?
No, this is the second pearl.
No, it's not.
It's the same pearl.
Yes, it is.
I saw it broke last time.
No, it didn't.
I've had 21 this entire time.
Oh, do I go down?
Oh, are you going forward?
I don't know.
I'm just thinking straight.
Should we do another eye?
Yeah, we can do another one.
Okay.
Okay, hold on.
Because the eye went...
It went kind of upward, so...
Alright, here I go.
Down!
It went down?
Where did it go?
Where did your eye go?
I didn't even see your eye.
I don't know.
Did it break?
We should make more space.
It's down though.
It's down for sure.
Oh gosh.
Alright, I made a spiral down.
Okay.
Did you make a spiral down?
Okay, yeah, yeah.
From where that was.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just keep going down.
Don't make it too big of a spiral.
Try to keep it tight.
Okay.
I'm letting the biome go.
It's pretty big.
We're in the savanna now.
We're in the savanna.
Now we're in water.
There's water right here.
Okay.
Oh, hello.
I guess we can't dig straight down.
There's literally water.
What do you want from me?
It's water.
The stronghold sucks.
The seed sucks.
Everything sucks.
I knew the seed was going to be an issue.
I knew the seed was going to be the biggest problem in the fucking world.
I think the first one was the best seed we've had.
Okay, so...
There's a giant cave.
Should we put the eye...
There's a giant cave here.
And I'm worried.
I don't like that.
Where's giant cave?
Oh gosh.
Over there.
You think it's under there?
You think it's in there?
Well, you got your bucket.
I got my boat too.
You wanna just get a boat and go down or get water?
We'll die.
Get the water.
I'm gonna throw an eye right now.
Can you see with the eye?
We should make more room for this eye.
Okay, let's make some room.
Is this enough room guys?
We have a lot, yeah.
So I think it's okay.
Alright, here we go.
But it was like over here that it went down.
So it might just go down.
Like, if it goes...
Okay, here we go.
What?
Where did it go?
Where did your eye go?
It didn't break.
I don't know.
It didn't break though.
What?
It's down?
It's just that way.
Oh, they always go up.
No, they don't.
One before went down, did it not?
Oh, it doesn't go down.
The fortress is always above Y0?
We are above Y0.
We are.
Where did it go?
I don't know.
Is this where we came from?
Are we going the right way?
I don't know where the eye went.
Which direction was the eye?
I did it from here.
And it went this way.
I'm so good.
Oh, it can go below.
That person is fucking lying.
Remember your name.
I'm gonna fucking remember your name now.
We've been through so much.
What's your fucking name?
I need a...
I'm gonna...
Yeah, okay.
That seems like a name that would lie to me.
The thing is...
The problem is that I'm scared now.
Because we can't find the eyes.
I don't want to keep using them.
And then wasting them.
Yeah.
How many do we need to open the portal?
It's 12, I think, right?
How many do we have now?
19.
I don't remember where it went.
My thing is...
I'm gonna make another pickaxe soon.
Because mine is about to break.
Uh-oh.
Don't use your pickaxe.
Just use your fist for this.
It's too late.
This is the worst fucking scene.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna start doing a...
A spiral staircase.
From here.
From here, okay.
Sorry, there's no going back.
Alright, alright.
What?
Oh, this is the giant cave?
Hold on, I'm looking.
Oh, diamond.
Okay.
Just ignore it for now.
What if it is in this cave?
Usually it's like...
Not in a cave cave, right?
What if it is?
What if...
What if everything we know...
Is wrong?
They said throw it in the cave.
Because there's a big space.
There's a big space.
I don't like that idea.
I don't know what else to do.
I think it's more over this way though.
We're at Y level negative 3.
Yeah, but they said...
Oh, there's water.
Oh my god.
That scared me.
I got pushed out.
Wait, we have to go back down.
Oh, there's...
Oh, that's not a drown.
Nevermind.
Oh my god.
I don't have the chairs...
The doors, so...
You don't have doors?
I'll go to you.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, it's fine.
Okay, so...
Here, I have some doors, so take them.
I don't have space.
Oh, throw away some cobblestone.
Got it.
Here comes a drown.
No, no, no.
I'm back in the area.
Come back.
I can't come back.
Where is it?
I can't get to you.
I'm here.
I don't know where.
Look at me.
Where is my shield?
I don't know where you are.
I'm literally in front of the door.
I'm in front of the door.
Did you eat?
I can't see anything.
I'm in front of the door.
I see you.
I can't see anything.
This is so bad.
This is it.
Come down!
I see you!
Follow me!
Why did you open the door?
I didn't open the door.
I was...
I was trying to get my shield up.
And then...
I couldn't see anything.
I couldn't see...
I literally could not see anything.
Where did you die?
I just want to know where the stronghold is.
Ok, I'll spectate.
No!
I can't spectate!
You can?
I can, but I'm back at our spawn point.
Where is your eyes?
Wait, can I teleport to you?
Where is your eye?
I just...
I just want to know where the stronghold is.
Oh my God!
I can't believe it!
I'm trying to find your eyes!
Press 1?
Oh, wait.
How do I do that?
Wait, what's 1 do?
Oh, teleport the player.
Oh, ok.
Ok, I'm by you.
Ok, hold on.
I'm trying to find...
I'm looking for the stronghold!
I'm looking for the...
I'm in the giant cave!
I'm looking for the stronghold!
I just want to know where the stronghold is.
That's all I want.
That's actually all I...
Um, where are you?
Hold on, I see it!
I just...
I just want to know where it is.
I don't want much.
I just want to know.
I'm freaking throwing away the bed.
I don't need it.
Where is your eyes?
Um...
We were so close to it.
We were...
Like...
Tell me where it is.
Wait, hold on, hold on.
No, this wouldn't have made it, but...
Right over...
Like...
A little...
Am I close?
Oh my god!
Are you kidding me?
Oh my god, I don't know if we would have survived.
Honestly though.
Because right inside the stronghold...
Is the trials!
What the...
We would have died from these things in here!
This is an absolute...
No, this is an absolute cursed...
No, this is a cursed, cursed seed.
This is a cursed...
This seed is absolutely cursed.
No, no, no, no, no.
Wait, really?
It was next to...
Am I close?
Where are you?
Where is it?
Hold on, let me teleport to you again.
This...
We had trials!
Within...
We would have had to go through trials to just get to...
That would have been funny though.
If we actually had to do that, that would have been...
This was the trial...
How many trials does this...
Do we have to go through?
That would have been funny though.
That would have been really funny if that was how we died.
Instead of the fucking...
No, instead I died to a fucking drown.
Because I just can't...
I hate the dumbest fucking enemy in the game!
I hate this!
Tell me where it is!
I want to see it struggle!
Okay, you're kind of far actually.
Oh, I'm far?!
It's like you're close, but far.
Like, it's a bit of a trek to get there.
Okay, how?
Which way?
Okay, hold on.
Where are you?
Let me see.
I have to find you again?
Hold on.
How...
How was there...
How was...
How could a trial be next to the fucking...
The merge with my stronghold?!
I don't know.
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to figure out...
I'm doing...
I'm gonna do spectate.
I'm gonna...
Are you gonna die?
No, I'm not.
I was like, how are you gonna spectate?
Where did that drown come from?
He came out of nowhere!
And then, we haven't had a drown...
With a pickaxe or whatever.
I tried it the entire time.
And then...
And then it happened.
It just happened.
And then it just happened.
How am I supposed to do...
I already...
What was it, guys?
How do I...
Slash game mode...
Spectator?
Oh my god.
I'm giving myself admin.
Give me a sec.
How do I...
How do I admin myself?
How do I mod myself?
Guys, how do I mod myself right now?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna mod myself.
Slash...
OP...
Unknown.
I'm gonna mod myself in the command.
How do I do it?
It says unknown or incomplete.
Okay, maybe O-P-N.
Alright, there we go.
Alright.
Where is it?
Where...
Where the fuck is this stronghold?
Where are you?
Where is it?
Are you in hell?
Yes, where is it?
Fall on your head.
So you have to go through here?
You have to go through here?
And then go down?
Look at this.
This is the stronghold?
But then over here?
If we...
Oh my god.
The trials are huge.
Is that the trials right there?
It's a copper ship!
Yes!
Oh my god!
What kind of LLC is this?
The portal has no eyes in it?
Would we even be able to fill it up?
Oh my god!
Where's the portal?
There's more over here!
Look at this!
We'd just be exploring and then...
Run into the trials!
There's insanity!
There's no eyes!
There's a spawner!
Oh my god!
And there's no eyes!
6, 7, 8, 9, 10...
No, we had enough.
It was 12.
Okay, we had enough.
Oh wow!
This is the worst seed ever!
There's another spawner right here!
We fought against this seed!
Every second!
We fought!
Fought!
This is rigged from the start!
It's rigged from the start!
How do I show you guys the seed?
How do I give you guys...
Oh my god!
God fears the seed!
Okay, now I'm gonna see what the seed is.
Look at this!
The trials!
Literally, we walk up this door and we'd be in the trials!
So absolutely cursed!
Have the seed!
Where are you?
That would be...
We would just be exploring and we would come upon the trials and then these guys would be released and we would just be dead!
We would just be doing the trials!
And actually we wouldn't even make it to the fucking...
We wouldn't even make it.
With our luck, we would not have made it to the fucking...
We had to dig underwater.
And they made the trials harder too in our core!
It was...
Oh my god, no!
If we dig...
Oh my god, if we had to dig...
We just had to dig in the mountain but it showed us not the mountain!
It showed us not the mountain!
If we dig...
Oh my god, if we dig from the underwater that we did we would have been in the trials.
If we went, if we followed the water if we dug in the water it would have been...
We would have dropped into the trial room.
We would have actually dropped into the trial room!
From down below, from the water!
It's literally the water area!
Oh my god, if we dug underwater and it told us to dig underwater too there was the worst part.
It was the worst part.
We would have landed in here.
You should go back into normal in the trials and see what happens.
Alright, I'm gonna go in.
What is this?
How do I get into the...
survival...
Wait, where are you?
This is the seed.
Here's the seed by the way so you can post it in your own.
This woke me up.
What is it?
Okay, you ready?
I'm next to you.
I'm gonna put in survival and see what happens.
Alright, here I am.
How does it work?
Here comes Ace.
Oh my god.
There's like poison skellies here.
How do I start the trials?
I think you just exist in here and the trials start.
Oh, here's the thing.
There you go.
Here's the breeze.
This is what we have to go through if we live this long.
If we live this long.
This is what we have to...
Oh my god, it's coming.
It's coming for me.
Oh my god, the poison skellies.
This is absolutely cursed.
Oh my god.
This is what I have to go through.
This is what I have to live through.
She's doing it, chat.
She's doing it.
Oh my god, my entire chat is just sound effects.
Oh my god.
So they just don't stop.
They just don't stop.
I can't even destroy this.
Oh my god.
I'm not okay.
I'm actually...
Oh my god, I'm not okay.
I'm not...
I got to the stragglers.
I'm in the stragglers.
This is the only way...
This is the only way to get out.
They can't open doors.
They can't...
Oh my god.
Oh, you killed him, guys.
You're full of arrows.
I made it to the stronghold.
Let's go.
Yippee.
Here's the coordinates, guys.
Here it is.
Oh my god.
I'm glad we...
I'm glad we ended up committing to see this bullshit.
Oh, now you can go again.
It opens right up into it.
Round two.
Oh my god.
There's no way.
I would've... I think if we had lived here, I just would've turned around and been like, go straight to the eye.
Don't look at anything else.
Don't even...
We can't even find the eye.
We don't even know where the eye was.
We don't even know where it was.
But I know we're in round two.
Oh my god.
There's some spawners up here.
It's in the chest.
It's like wooden axes.
This sucks.
Oh my god.
This is the worst edition ever to Minecraft.
I can break the trial rule.
I can be like, I'm fucking out.
They're not supposed to merge, right?
I don't think so.
I've never seen this before.
They're not supposed to merge, right?
Are they supposed to merge?
Is this supposed to happen?
No, someone said...
It's not supposed to.
Someone literally said it's not supposed to.
Oh my god.
I'm filing a complaint with Minecraft.
Why?
Why is there a sea blade?
What was the scene?
I posted it in our chat.
You can post it.
Okay, thank you.
This is the scene for anybody who wants to explore.
Have fun.
Have fun in this hellhole.
I'm gonna...
Enjoy.
Have fun.
I'm gonna delete this world.
I'm deleting this world.
What?
Is this the outside?
This is the outside of the trial.
This is the newest version.
This is actually...
The trials are huge.
It's humongous.
It never ends.
I'm gonna sleep through the night.
Where did you go?
I don't know.
I'm going back to spectate.
I need to know where I...
I need to know where I went to.
Oh my god.
This is actually...
Just a bunch of potatoes.
Why is the loot in here so terrible?
What was the point of being in the trials?
What was the point?
Where is the end?
I don't even know.
I went all the way from here.
I'm going to the ender dragon.
I'm fucking... I'm going in.
How are you going to the ender dragon?
I'm going to the ender dragon.
How do I go to the end?
How do I...
How do I teleport to you?
You have to probably...
Go to the eye and then put in the thing.
Oh my god.
I'm going in.
Get this shit out of here.
Get this...
You got all my stuff?
No, I'm fucking in creative mode.
I'm in creative.
Can you change my mode?
Since you're admin.
I can.
Game mode, creative.
There we go.
Yeah!
I'm back!
I'm back, baby!
Get the eye.
Get the eye and put it in.
We're doing a survival.
We've suffered enough.
Get in here.
We're going in.
We're going to finish this scene.
We're going to...
Oh my god, we're in the worst spot.
This is so...
We haven't even had enough to get...
I had to...
Oh my god.
I'm fucking...
Come on, let's go beat this fucker.
Let's go.
Get the right sword.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Guys, I told you I could...
We're doing it.
No, you don't get to have that.
You don't get to have that either.
For this one.
Kill him.
Oh wait, there is one more.
Fly.
We have the point of everything we did.
What was the point?
Oh my god.
Do your fucking thing now.
Do it.
We're so touched.
Oh, you're charging.
This whole scene.
This is so cathartic right now.
I've done...
14 hours of this.
Almost 14 hours.
And then...
They had to put a child.
Die, you gotta die.
The dragon died.
The honey wasn't in the water.
Everything, screw you.
Screw this whole world.
Everybody in this world deserves to die.
This whole...
I'm deleting this world right after we kill this dragon.
This world will cease to exist.
This world will cease to exist right after.
Cease to exist.
Come on, a little bit more.
Yeah,
I'm talking about you too.
That's fucking right.
Let's go in there, come on.
Let's go.
Guys, we did it, we beat the ender dragon.
We beat the ender dragon.
It's over.
Holy fuck.
It's actually...
It's over.
It's a kill.
Oh my god.
I'm crying.
I'm fucking crying.
I can't believe.
Oh my god.
The seed.
The seed is not meant for men.
Oh my god.
I
can't believe.
I can't even see the end spot.
We somehow managed to survive all of that.
Seriously, I thought our luck was turning around when I just happened to come across the fortress.
I was like, oh my god, wait.
This is actually doable, we can do this.
And then...
Everything.
Everything changed.
The entire cosmos was against us.
That's right, it's true.
Oh my god.
How did we get the seed?
How did we get it?
If only we didn't throw it in the beginning.
We would have had the best...
All the other seeds we had started out so well.
And then we were like, you know what?
Hopper gets to go to fight with this one.
We got this.
It can't be.
Oh my god.
We can finally sleep.
I'm glad we toughened it out.
To just see what it was like at the end.
Just to see.
I think if we went to bed and we were like, let's do the end and try it tomorrow.
That we would not have survived.
No, we wouldn't have survived.
It would have been the fastest second stream.
Oh my god.
It was rigged from the start.
I'm glad that we have all of that on camera.
I'm glad.
Just me finding the stronghold and them being like, what the...
What are the trials?
The trials are connection.
And they were like, it's not supposed to merge.
It's not supposed to merge.
But yet, somehow.
I like how someone was like, you shouldn't have cheated.
What?
After everything.
We have this.
We played fair the entire time.
We played fair.
We didn't even give you the seed.
We tried so hard.
And now you're like, you shouldn't have cheated.
Seeds get degrees.
And you know what letter cheater starts with?
We needed this.
We were so cathartic.
Killing the dragon after everything we've been through.
I can't believe the trials.
The trials would have killed us.
If anything.
Oh my god.
Someone just said the seed cheated first.
Yes!
The seed cheated first.
It was all the seed's fault.
It was the seed's fault.
Even chat was like, give us the seed.
We'll find the fortress for you.
Give us the seed.
You guys need to sleep.
Go to bed.
Just do it tomorrow.
If we did this tomorrow, this would have hurt even more.
This would have hurt even more.
If we went to bed and tried to do this tomorrow.
Oh my god.
Someone made a good point too.
You don't even know what the trials look like.
So you would have just walked right in.
And then our armor would be broken before we get to the end.
If we survived the trials, our armor would be broken.
We would have no resources for the ending.
Here's the seed, everybody.
Seed of this world.
If you guys want to try and do the seed of this world.
Here, I'll pin it.
Here you go, everybody.
Enjoy, have fun.
I think this is the most us ending.
Only we could have conjured this to happen.
After literally all the bullshit we went through.
Everything.
Oh my god.
It's the perfect ending.
It truly was.
Oh gosh.
Okay, I'll see you next week.
Next time when we do it legit.
I guess.
We will try it legitimately again.
We'll try one day.
We just need to recover from this.
We need to recover.
When we wanted to do this.
We didn't think this was going to happen.
We didn't think we would.
We would go through such pain.
For those who wanted the coordinates of the stronghold.
I pressed F3.
When we were exploring the trial room.
So just find that in the VOD.
I'm done.
Yeah, I think I'm going to go to sleep now.
Me too.
I have this rush of adrenaline.
I did too.
When we found the trial rooms.
I woke the fuck up.
I was filled with so much anger.
And disbelief.
We spent like an hour.
Prepping for the ender dragon.
While we were sleep deprived.
We spent an hour.
Just leveling up.
Just not to know.
That it was just unwinnable in the end.
It was never winnable.
You know what's probably the case too.
Is that stronghold.
That your chat mentioned.
That you passed over.
Probably was way easier.
Probably was a proper stronghold.
Okay, you're right.
It probably was.
We got sent to the bullshit one.
We followed the eyes.
Just to be here.
Oh my god.
Just to be.
No, I'm deleting this scene.
We're starting on a new scene.
When we're doing this again.
We're not doing this again.
I'm deleting the world.
They're telling us to wake up.
We haven't even gone to sleep yet.
Wake up.
I lost my dogs in this scene.
Twice.
We had that weird glitch.
I woke up and they were gone.
It's like they never existed.
They never existed.
In my life.
My first dog just disappeared.
Just disappeared.
How do I escape from the...
Oh, there we go.
You press space bar.
I'm back.
I'm in the fucking...
I'm in the bed.
I'm in the trials.
I'm back.
I never left.
I never left town.
I'm back in our...
In this initial spawn point.
Are you coming to me?
I'll come to you.
I'm literally in front of you.
Oh my god.
Let's see where the Eye of Ender takes us now.
Come on Eye of Ender.
Take us to a better...
Are you serious?
No, it's still going.
Yeah, it's still going.
I'm following the eye.
I'm gonna TP to you again.
Okay.
I hate this seed.
I wanna burn everything down.
I hate this seed so much.
I wanna...
I hate this seed.
Oh, it's right here.
Wait.
No, it's right here.
Oh, nevermind.
It's still going.
It's right here.
Just keep going.
I wanna know what a good seed...
What a good stronghold actually looks like.
I wanna know.
We're going.
We just wanna know.
What's it called?
What's the...
What's what called?
Slash...
Locate...
Structure...
Minecraft...
15...
1506 blocks away.
150...
You can...
You're just gonna burn the forest down.
Yeah, I'm burning everything.
You're just gonna...
I'm gonna go in the cave.
I'm just going... I'm going spectator mode.
I'm fucking...
I can't change my mode, so I'm stuck in creative.
Okay.
It's fine.
Where is this hellhole?
Where is the second hellhole?
Burn.
Minna's burning it all down.
She's burning it all down.
Burninating the piggies.
Burninating everything in sight.
And all the cottages.
Little cottages.
It didn't load.
What didn't load?
The stronghold.
Oh, look, another trout.
Oh, we broke it.
Oh, game mode.
Creative.
Wait, teleport me to you.
How do I... Wait.
How do I teleport to you?
Wait, no, no, not yet.
Don't yet.
Don't do it yet.
I fucking broke it.
What do you mean you broke it?
What did you break?
I teleported somewhere, but it's not working.
Uh-oh.
Okay, proceed.
I'm leaving.
Where am I?
Game mode.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm trying to find it.
I'm trying to find the other stronghold.
Where is it?
It literally gave you the coordinates.
Just click it.
It took me to some...
It fucked up.
What?
Like here?
Is this the same area?
No.
Oh, my God.
It took us to...
There's the trials.
This is...
No way.
There's...
This stronghold had another trial.
Teleport me.
Okay.
No fucking way.
Are you serious?
Put me in spectator mode.
Okay, and then...
Game mode.
Spectator.
Look down.
Oh, wait.
Did you...
Oh, no.
I forgot.
I forgot the server.
We can go back in.
I'm waiting for the server to come back.
I'm leaving.
I can't believe it.
This other stronghold.
I'm in.
The other stronghold had...
Oh, my God.
Wait, where are we?
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna locate.
Locate structure...
Stronghold.
The other...
The other one...
Had one, too.
Are you sure it's not the same one?
No.
No, it's not.
I know it's not.
Oh, yeah.
I'm already in spectator.
Okay, wait.
I know it's not.
That's the thing.
Oh, wait.
I'm not in spectator anymore.
Teleport me.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to head to the...
Okay, it's like...
Game mode spec.
I need to go as spectator to find this again.
Okay, I found.
Okay, so...
Oh, my God.
There's no way.
It's literally...
It's not there.
Oh, my God.
I am wide awake now.
I don't know how I'm gonna get to sleep.
It's a different stronghold.
It's a different one.
Okay.
Game mode...
Creative...
Okay, wait.
Sorry.
Game mode, not creative.
Spectator.
Go down.
Look down.
Go down?
Oh, my God.
We have to go through...
We have to go through the trials.
We have to dig through the trials.
To get to the stronghold.
Oh, my God.
It is a different one.
This is not the same one.
The stronghold is below.
The fucking trials.
They're like, you will do the trials.
No matter where you go.
You will do these trials.
You won't get away.
Oh, my God.
You will never leave.
This is the...
Did you find the eye?
Where is it?
Where even is the eye?
Wait, is it below?
Oh, yeah.
It's below.
Where even is it?
The eye is...
Wait, that's just a...
Where even is the eye?
I can't even tell.
Where is the eye?
I found the bookshelf.
I found...
Where is it?
There's no portal.
There's no portal room.
There's no way.
I think this is supposed to be the portal room.
And it's just a random...
Wait, what?
It's just a random...
It's just like a random...
It's like a random...
I think this is supposed to be the portal room.
I got eaten by a geode.
Oh, my God.
No, there's...
Wait, there has to be...
Maybe we passed it.
Oh, I found it!
I found it!
Oh, my God.
It also has no eyes in it though.
Okay, I found it.
Oh, my God.
There's no way.
That would have been absolute cinema.
Right there.
Oh, my God.
I wish...
I wish the amethyst did eat the fucking portal room.
Why is there no eyes?
It also has no eyes, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Wait, where did it go?
I found it and I lost it.
It's so easy to lose.
Oh, my God.
It's so far away.
It's so far away, right?
It's like past the trials.
Why is this trial so fucking big?
Lush pile.
This seed.
I hate this seed.
This is making the staff so fucking awake.
It feels like someone purposefully made this.
This wasn't randomly generated.
This was the one...
The staff just to make the seed.
And he's like...
One day, someone is gonna hit that seed.
One day.
Oh, my God.
Wait, what's the nether like for this one too?
No, there's no way it would be that bad, right?
You're going to the nether too?
No, not nether.
I meant the eye.
I can't find the eye.
Hold on, I'm gonna teleport to you.
Okay, yeah.
Place the eyes in there.
Let's see how bad the spawn is.
Oh, they're the same?
Oh, it doesn't matter.
It was just the seed.
It was just the seed that gave us the fucking terrible...
Alright, it didn't matter.
It didn't fucking matter.
Apparently, it's the same spawn.
It's the same end spawn.
It wouldn't matter.
It's just the seed.
It's based off of all the seed.
Wow.
It was truly...
Where did the trials disappear to?
It's the other side.
It's the opposite side of the fucking portal.
Oh my god.
They're not even connected.
What is this stronghold?
What is this?
What?
You have to go all the way over...
All the way here?
For the eye?
How do you get here?
What do you mean?
It's not connected properly.
It's bonkers.
Oh my god.
I don't even know how you get to this.
What?
It's not connected with the portal area.
Yep.
Yeah.
Okay, you go down here.
And then you're in a dead end.
You just got a mine.
You have to know what walls to knock down.
You got a fucking mine to the portal.
It's amazing we got this far.
It's actually amazing.
It's actually amazing that we got this far.
It's amazing we didn't make it.
We were never meant to make it to the stronghold.
Yeah, we were.
We were never meant to.
GGs, Mint.
GGs, Doki.
I'm glad we stuck it out just to see this hellhole now.
I know.
You know what?
Maybe dying right before seeing that atrocity just brought inner peace to me.
I think if we rested and tried this tomorrow, we would have been even more angry.
I know.
We would have realized we were well-rested just to find out it was always against us.
We were never meant to beat the sea.
With how far away the stronghold was still from where I died, I think it would have taken us another hour or so to find it.
At least.
Oh my god.
The drown with the trident was just like, I'm saving you.
Don't keep going.
Don't do it.
I'm putting you out of your misery.
It's over.
Turn back.
Oh my god.
Thank you everybody for going on this journey with us.
Wild adventure.
I can't wait to do this again.
The sun is literally up so I'm going to go attempt some sleep for a couple hours.
Me too.
I have dance lessons later.
Oh my god.
GG everybody.
GG everyone.
We're both going to head to bed now.
I'll talk to you later.
Go sleep.
Remember to check out our tickets by the way.
Check out our concert tickets.
That will be sold out.
We'll play Minecraft in 3D.
We'll do the seed in 3D.
We'll do the seed again in 3D.
We have the seed numbers anyway.
If we sell out the concert we'll do this exact seed in 3D.
GG everybody.
Bye bye.
Can I send you this real quick?
Hold on.
Look at this tweet.
Oh my god.
I just saw your tweet.
I hate the seed so much.
There were so many struggles.
There were so many things to us.
How?
Oh my god.
I'm leaving.
I'm done.
I'm fucking done.
Bye.
Goodnight everybody.
Or good morning.
Bye.
Bye bye.
Oh my god.
I'll see you guys later everybody.
As always stay hydrated, posture checked, get up and around to get that blood flow.
If you stayed up for me I'd defend because you deserve it.
Oh my god.
For those who wondered what I saw.
This is what we saw.
Oh my god.
I'll show this image again.
This is our pathway to the stronghold.
We miss everything.
I managed to miss every single stronghold.
I don't know.
Anyway.
I'll see you guys later everybody.
Bye.
Oh my god.
I'm so tired.